ん
今日はこちらしていいですいつも英語で微量あってやってるんですよね
だから今日はもうスペイン語と日本語で語尾をやろうと思っています
でこの内容がねやはり今私は3ヶ月間
この韓国語に集中して
こう挑戦してるわけですよその巨泉の意味はですね
この3ヶ月間以内にねこの
非常にこうすばらしいそういうに多数
粒状に韓国を話そうとそうそういうことを地無しにこの3ヶ月間の間にこの
あれですよこの高主従的にこれを毎日1時間の2時間も3できれば3時間もこの韓国語
にこの
あるんですよ
使う
え
だからこれあの活動のレベルでの挑戦ですよね
a
これがこの目標とか
どれほどよく話せるかというもんじゃなくて取れハどれほどその韓国語で頑張ろう
たという挑戦ですよね
で
この言葉勉強するにはやはり
3つの一番大切な要素があるわけですよね
一つはその1勉強する人の態度
第2それが時間も時間が必要なんですよね
第3話ですねこの言葉の何が起こっているかと言うように対して敏感にならないと
いけないんですよ注意しないといけないんですよ
で
韓国を今私は不法集中的にやってるから
非常に面白いぽって革シート見つかったんですよ
けんじょんべえ
これはねもう政治
歴史政治についてのを超えてください出てきしてもあるわけですよ
で興味のある方がいらっしゃれば僕は彼のリンクも載せますけれどもそれでは
も白いこのなヨガまああればまあ私の態度
このね値が上がるわけですよそれが非常に大切でしょ
それ第2話時間
今日できるだけもういやでももう韓国もビッグする
毎日そういう気持ちで居るんですけれども
えまあそれはいつでもできるわけではないんですけどもできるだけ口を集中的に
だから異国までポーランド語も行ったりですねウクライナ語も行ったりいろいろやった
けれども処理は多いとおいて
可能
観光後に集中しようとそれから第二でそういうことをやる
結果としてね色んなことですねたん国号の
ま合意でもその言葉のコードでも私がもっと子
9位できるようになっているわけですよ
いうことでへ
この聞くと聴くとあの読むだけでいわゆる多読多聴
というその勉強法なんですけども
私のニス元前のうちの韓国人のメンバーの花さんとの
話とそして1週間前のその話のこのビデオをご覧になればかなりの進歩があったわけ
ですよ
はなさんもそう言ってくれたんですよね難しい
その間に私はちっとも話ししてないんですよただ聞くと酔うだけでこの言葉に慣れて
くるわけですよ
それが良いように大事なんですよまあ
そういうことで今日はちょっとだけ日本語で
で話題の日本も全然話してないから始まったときにちょっともうやりづらいあったん
ですけれども
もうちょい少しずつ少しずつ慣れてくるとこれだけの日本語も少しずつ良くなってくる
んですよ
だから a それも大事なんでしょ
うちの言葉がやらなくてもそしてもう一度始まるときには最初は難しいけれどもやる
ことによって段々と
また前の水運に
戻ります回復されるんですよはいじゃあ度も
さいなら